de nouvelles brigades dans dans les
Yvelines alors vous avez tenu aussi
l'audience solennelle avec le président
du tribunal judiciaire de Versailles
Bertrand menest et vendredi dernier
globalement quel message vous souhaitiez
faire passer lors de ce rendez-vous
j'avais déjà un message de plaisir à
faire passer qui était la possibilité de
tenir enfin une audience solennelle de
rentrer en grand format c'est-à-dire
d'accueillir tout nos partenaires nos
collaborateurs ou les gens avec lesquels
on travaille au quotidien c'est
important c'est une fois dans l'année
donc c'est rare donc c'est précieux et
puis peut-être un petit peu plus
sérieusement mais non moins sincèrement
ce que je voulais faire passer c'était
en prenant un exemple au delà des
chiffres d'augmentation de l'un
délinquance mais je dirais c'est une
progression que l'on retrouve assez
normalement après la période de covid on
n'a pas tout à fait retrouvé les niveaux
de 2019 mais ça remonte vraiment très
sérieusement c'est sur la base du
contentieux des violences
intra-familliales de montrer que on ne
pouvait pas imaginer d'absorber un
contentieux qui explose de cette manière
là à coup zéro
avant de revenir justement sur rentrer
dans les détails par rapport aux
violences familiales j'aimerais revenir
sur une citation qui moi m'a marqué
j'étais présent lors de cette audience
solennelle je vous cite nous avons le
sens du service public et quoi qu'il en
coûte sachant que le nous vous parlez
des magistrats et des fonctionnaires du
tribunal judiciaire donc je reprends
nous avons le sens du service public et
quoi qu'il en coûte nous avons toujours
envie que l'institution fonctionne
peut-être qu'un jour ça nous perdra et
ce phénomène a peut-être déjà commencé
fin de citation qu'est-ce qu'elle
raconte cette cette phrase en fait
quelle est la réalité aujourd'hui du
tribunal judiciaire de Versailles en
tant que procureur de la République je
parle plus particulièrement des
magistrats du parquet ce que je souhaite
dire par ce genre de propos c'est que
c'est aussi un écho à la fameuse tribune
qui évidemment a pris beaucoup d'ampleur
et beaucoup de place dans nos
discussions et dans nos juridictions et
qui a montré que justement cette ce
métier qui nous dépasse en fait et pour
lequel on peut déployer beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup d'heures beaucoup de
travail sans forcément avoir la
rémunération qui va bien et la
reconnaissance qui va bien on est
peut-être effectivement dans une période
de changement par rapport à ça et la
nécessité de reconnaître que un travail
mérite sa récompense quel que soit ce
travail évidemment et que donc il faut
et là je rejoins un petit peu ce que je
disais reconnaître que cette envie de
que ça fonctionne en y mettant du temps
et de l'énergie et bien ça ne peut pas
se faire sans un certain nombre de
moyens juste pour que nos
téléspectateurs comprennent madame la
procureur vient de parler d'une tribune
en fait l'année dernière c'était en
novembre 2021 et bien il y a 3000
magistrats et puis en plus c'est bon
en fait dans la presse pour appeler et
bien aux conditions compliquées
d'exercice de leur activité et ça ça
faisait suite en fait à une magistrate
une de vos collègues qui s'était et bien
suicidé à l'été 2021 aujourd'hui il y a
des cas de Burn Out au tribunal
judiciaire de Versailles il y a des
situations assez délicates en termes de
condition de travail et de santé des
collaborateurs
la santé les conditions de travail au
tribunal de judiciaire de Versailles
sont une préoccupation qui est très
importante pour le président et moi-même
et donc nous essayons autant que faire
ce peu d'avoir connaissance de ces
conditions et de la qualité avec
laquelle les magistrats et les
fonctionnaires peuvent travailler en
plus nous sommes soutenus en cela par
les chefs de cours qui ont pris ce sujet
à bras le corps et qui ont déployé
recruté et déployés des psychologues
spécialisés qui sont à disposition et à
demeure dans nos juridictions de façon à
être en capacité de recevoir les
personnes qui en ont besoin donc ce sont
des thématiques qui ont pris beaucoup de
place par rapport à ce que j'ai pu
connaître moi je dirais autrefois et
c'est tout à fait normal dans un
contexte on l'a rappelé un augmentation
des procédures vous êtes passé de 9065
procédures en 2019 à
93351 une augmentation d'environ 3,5%
sans pour autant qui est forcément de
moyens supplémentaires en face est-ce
que la solution viendra par une
augmentation justement de ces moyens
comme l'annoncé le ministre de la
Justice de garde des sceaux Eric
Dupont-Moretti 5 janvier dernier écoutez
le fait que le budget de la justice soit
spectaculairement augmenté et bien un
signe qu'il fallait un rattrapage ça je
pense que c'est un constat objectif de
base après si vous voulez le sujet des
moyens c'est toujours quelque chose qui
nous est reproché en disant vous ne
savez que Jade et demander davantage ce
qu'on peut constater c'est que quand il
y a des moyens la justice elle
fonctionne et si on prend quelques
process spectaculaires alors je fais
attention avec le mot spectaculaire mais
en tout cas des procès dit terroristes
qui ont lieu dernièrement ou la justice
est donnée les moyens d'avoir
matériellement et humainement la
capacité à les régler à rendre cette
justice et notamment je pense à V13 et
bien on voit que ça fonctionne donc je
dirais que c'est peut-être une
démonstration par le concret alors tout
à l'heure vous avez parlé des violences
intra familiales on peut dire que c'est
un peu le quotidien du du tribunal de
l'activité pénale du Tribunal judiciaire
de Versailles parce que vous l'avez dit
durant l'audience solennelle c'est très
majoritairement
à ce contentieux là qui qui vous
concerne au quotidien et vous avez même
parlé que aujourd'hui vous êtes
quasiment dans une situation mais que
connaissent les urgences hospitalières
et que vous êtes obligé de traiter de
trier les affaires que que vous traitez
je crois qu'il y a 123 à faire
actuellement qui sont dans les armoires
depuis 2020 et qui ne sont pas traités
qui attend effectivement d'être jugé
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une audience pour
que les personnes auteurs ou victimes
puissent voir leur procès juger
effectivement alors les violences
intrafamiliales ne sont pas le seul
contentieux que l'on traite au tribunal
judiciaire loin de là et je voudrais pas
que le doute s'installe par rapport à ça
c'est simplement ce que je voulais
montrer c'est une explosion vraiment
très très importante qui fait que ce
contentieux en fait c'est inséré dans
tous les contentieux que l'on traite
sans que les autres contentionnées
disparaissent et donc ils les a
simplement fait reculer donc si on fait
reculer quelque chose et qu'on met
quelque chose de vent c'est une forme de
priorisation c'est mon rôle en tant que
en tant que chef de juridique son chef
du Parquet néanmoins ce n'est pas sans
conséquence tout à fait négative pour
ceux qui attendent alors pour rentrer
sur le fond du sujet des violences
intrafamilales c'est c'est un sujet
d'importance quand même dans le
département entier avec les différents
acteurs vos différents partenaires
puisque deux fois par an vous réunissez
ce qu'on appelle le comité local d'aide
aux victimes et ce comité local des deux
victimes est vraiment dédié à ces
violences là effectivement dans le
département nous l'avons désacracation
dédiée aux violences intrafamiliales et
on se début d'année nous avons même
ajouté une thématique et celle des
violences faites au mineur au mineur
pardon qu'elles soient dans ce contexte
là ou dans un contexte ni plus ni moins
grave très grave qui est celui des
violences sexuelles qui doivent être
traitées et qui méritent d'être traités
outre ce contentieux particulier donc
effectivement c'est une thématique
importante
et qui les naturels de traiter et je
l'ai dit vendredi dernier c'est même une
fierté à un honneur pour un état de
droit que de traiter enfin ce
contentieux-là simplement ce qu'il faut
bien savoir c'est que il ne suffit pas
d'avoir des outils il ne suffit pas
d'avoir un téléphone grand danger un
bracelet anti-rapprochement il faut
derrière tous ces outils des personnes
pour suivre la mise en oeuvre et donc on
ne peut pas simplement dire aux
juridictions et bien vous avez tous les
moyens vous avez toutes les lois vous
avez tous les dispositifs maintenant ça
ne doit plus arriver ça n'est pas aussi
simple que ça un dernier mot quels sont
les grands rendez-vous à ne pas manquer
en 2023 pour le tribunal judiciaire de
Versailles et bien c'est continuer de
déployer son dynamisme son énergie
d'avoir des idées de défendre aussi ce
qu'il a besoin de défendre c'est à dire
de faire les demandes qui vont bien et
puis de s'intéresser aux conclusions des
États généraux qui vont d'une manière ou
d'une autre nous concerner notamment
s'agissant de la réforme ou de la
roquefortification pardon du code de
procédure pénale merci Maryvonne
Caillebotte je le rappelle procureur de
la République de Versailles merci
d'avoir été avec nous